ils luttent pour leur entreprise et
contre une sérieuse impression de déjà
vu
comme en 2018 peugeot japy est à
reprendre ou à laisser on n'a pas
démérité
au contraire on a tout fait on a investi
on l'a on la prophétie en qualité donc
maintenant voilà les gens comprennent
pas pourquoi payer ça divise par deux
pratiquement leur chiffre d'affaires
'l'annonce a jeté comme un froid
vendredi dernier alors que trois des
quatres repreneurs potentiels de jappy
sont dans les murs à quelques kilomètres
de là psa l'unique et omnipotent clients
lusine fait savoir qu'il envisage de
réduire son volume de commandes
il passerait de 30 à 17 millions d'euros
l'an prochain
une catastrophe financière qui tombe au
pire moment aucun risque et pas de
reprise
quand vous voyez certaines offres qui
sont conditionnées notamment celle de
monsieur chevrier qui a conditionné à 25
millions de chiffre d'affaires lui en
dessous il ne reprend pas la société on
se dit est ce que les autres ne vont pas
suivre le même chemin aujourd'hui si psa
ne nous suit pas on n'a pas d'avenir
clairement les cartes sont dans les
mêmes psa pour les 240 salariés du site
il n'y a qu'une seule explication psa
s'apprête à sous-traiter à l'étranger à
l'heure du monde après celui où les plus
grands exhorte les entreprises à
produire en france
l'incompréhension est totale et le ton
pourrait donc vite monter dans cette
usine qui fabrique quelques pièces clés
nous sommes là juste pour envoyer un
message d alerte on ne met plus tard si
lui ne veut pas comprendre le message d
alerte peut-être qu'on l'a on envisagera
une grève en illimité aujourd'hui danse
vraiment pour lui faire un signe qu'on
est là qu'on existe qu'on n'est pas
juste une comptable dans ses cahiers des
négociations devraient avoir lieu dans
les prochains jours pour clarifier la
position de psa mais le temps presse
le tribunal de commerce doit examiner
les projets de reprise le 15 septembre